[Musik]
in berlin bin ich jetzt dazu verbunden
mit rainer hoffmann vorsitzender des
deutschen gewerkschaftsbundes dgb
hoffmann wir grüßen sie in die
hauptstadt wir haben schon eine gewisse
vorlage bekommen durch den film aber
noch mal nachgefragt warum brauchen wir
das recht auf home office aus ihrer
sicht liegen morgen freiland wir
brauchen das recht auf home office jetzt
gerade in diesen zeiten um den
infektionsverlauf deutlich einzugrenzen
da ist das home office ein mittel der
wahl um die infektions verläufe deutlich
zurück zu drängen
darüber hinaus sind wir allerdings schon
der auffassung wie bundesarbeitsminister
hubertus heil dass menschen auch mehr
rechtsansprüche auf zeitsouveränität
brauchen da wo home office möglich ist
darf das nicht von den arbeitgebern
verwehrt werden
apropos wert welcher evidenz haben sie
denn eigentlich dass dieses aufrechter
form auf es nicht gewährt wird haben sie
studien gemacht
befragungen wir haben von unseren
kollegen und kollegen aus den acht
mitgliedsgewerkschaften ganz
unterschiedliche rückmeldungen
ich unterstreiche dass es in vielen
betrieben insbesondere da wo es betriebs
und personalräte gibt in der regel
wirklich gut läuft aber wir haben in der
tat viel zu viele arbeitgeber die auf
dem herr im hause standpunkt pochen und
darauf bestehen dass ihre beschäftigten
an den arbeitsplatz kommen das ist
gerade unter den bedingungen der
pandemie nicht verantwortlich wenn wir
das infektionsgeschehen deutlich
zurückdrängen wollen sie haben den
bundesarbeitsminister robertos heil
angesprochen der hat ja dann sozusagen
noch mal nachgelegt nachgebessert einen
neuen gesetzentwurf jetzt in der
ressortabstimmung und der sagt relativ
konkret es gibt das recht auf ein
gespräch und es gibt die pflicht zur
begründung warum reicht ihnen das nicht
ja weil wir wollen schon dass in den
betrieben die betriebs und personalräte
ein verbindliches mitspracherecht
bekommen
das ist mehr als nur das angebot
unverbindliche gespräche mit dem
arbeitgeber zu führen und wir müssen mit
berücksichtigen dass beschäftigte heute
ganz unterschiedliche vorstellungen von
ihren arbeitszeiten haben wenn es
beispielsweise um die vereinbarkeit von
familie und beruf geht dem dürfen die
arbeitgeber sich mich entgegenstellen
überall dort wo home office möglich ist
sollten die beschäftigten auch einen
rechtsanspruch haben davon gebrauch zu
machen
formell gibt es ja jetzt
formaljuristisch seit anfang des jahres
also die möglichkeit dass in einer
verordnung auch zu lösen das wäre ja
durchaus sozusagen zwischen variante
denn im moment sehe ich jetzt nicht ganz
die mehrheit für ihre idee im bundestag
ja wir müssen natürlich jetzt unter den
bedingungen der pandemie noch einmal
besonders berücksichtigen dass damit
auch einen beitrag zum gesundheitsschutz
geleistet werden kann
wir haben aber auch die unternehmen
worum office schlicht und ergreifend
nicht machbar ist da gilt es das jetzt
die arbeitsstandards durchgesetzt werden
die gemeinsam mit den arbeitgebern und
dem bundesarbeitsministerium vereinbart
wurde zum schutz der beschäftigten in
den betrieben betriebe sind häufig
weniger von infektions verläufen
betroffen das wissen wir aber auf dem
weg zur arbeit zurück nach hause abends
ist das risiko sich zu infizieren
deutlich größer
deshalb macht das recht auf home office
gerade in zeiten der pandemie besonders
sinn und ich erinnere daran dass gerade
in unseren nachbarländern frankreich
belgien vor wenigen tagen ein
rechtsanspruch durchgesetzt wurde
die arbeitgeber sind verpflichtet dort
wo home office möglich ist gerade unsere
zeiten der pandemie dieses den
beschäftigten nicht zu verwehren heraus
man noch mal sozusagen zur präzisierung
auch des ganzen sie haben es durchaus
auch noch die nachbarländer angesprochen
wir in deutschland wenn ich jetzt diesen
etwas belegten begriffe verwenden da für
uns ist ja vieles rund um die
digitalisierung noch neuland da gibt es
sozusagen die frage des home office und
das
mobilen arbeitens in der trennschärfe
ist das ja durchaus nicht dasselbe aber
ihr fokus ist tatsächlich die die frage
dass ich zu hause von meinem küchentisch
ausarbeiten kann wenn ich dann kein
arbeitszimmer habe völlig richtig
mobiles arbeiten ist auch in der
vergangenheit schon ein standard für
viele beschäftigte gewesen
die beispielsweise auf kundenbesuche
sind die auf baustellen auf wechselnden
baustellen eingesetzt werden all das
fällt unter mobiles arbeiten aber das
home-office da wo tätigkeiten nicht im
büro am schreibtisch sondern auch im
eigenen homeoffice geleistet werden
können da brauchen die menschen
rechtssicherheit und auch die
möglichkeit davon gebrauch zu machen
diese differenzierung ist völlig richtig
er ruft man die rechtssicherheit ist
schön und gut was wir bisher noch im
blick nehmen müssen ist sozusagen unsere
gesamtsituation der deutschen wirtschaft
wir haben ziemlich im stück erlebt im
jahr 2020 wieder ein leichtes aufrappeln
jetzt gibt es den neuen lockdown es gibt
sozusagen auch die debatte um einen ganz
scharfen wirtschaftlichen lockdown
würden sie sich dem anschließen wäre das
auch eine option für sie zum gegenwert
im zentrum würden wir uns dem mit
sicherheit nicht anschließen natürlich
haben auch gewerkschaft und ein
interesse daran dass die unternehmen gut
durch die pandemie kommen dass
beschäftigung gesichert wird das ist
eines der ganz zentralen zielsetzungen
aber wenn wir beschäftigung sichern
wollen dann heißt das dass wir den
unternehmen unter die arme greifen
völlig richtig dafür sind milliarden
hilfen der bundesregierung und der
länder zur verfügung gestellt worden
das hilft auch in weiten bereichen aber
dazu gehört natürlich denn auch im
interesse der beschäftigten zu sehen was
kann darüber hinaus gemacht werden und
da ist der gesundheitsschutz am
arbeitsplatz ein ganz zentrales gebot
und da wo der arbeitsplatz nicht
aufgesucht werden muss sollte man
wirklich in der jetzigen situation
fahrzeiten zur arbeit abends zurück nach
hause vermeiden um das
infektionsgeschehen einzugrenzen und
dann auch den menschen mehr
möglichkeiten zur selbstbestimmung ihrer
arbeitszeiten ob im home-office oder
zuhause gewähren
ich sage aber auch wir haben gerade in
den letzten monaten erfahren
gemacht die uns nicht zufriedenstellen
können insbesondere frauen sind in ganz
besonderer weise betroffen ist kann
nicht sein dass erziehungsarbeit und
homeoffice gleichzeitig von den frauen
geschultert wird diese doppelbelastung
führt uns zurück in traditionelle
geschlechterrollen das wollen wir auf
gar keinen fall
deshalb sage ich auch hier müssen wir
mit in den blick nehmen dass wenn frauen
oder wenn familien aufgrund der
schließung von kitas von schulen nicht
zur arbeit können um sorge- arbeit zu
leisten dass sie dafür freigestellt
werden und dann auch nicht zum home
office fördern hat werden
herr hoffmann botschaft angekommen wenn
wir mehr zeit für ein zweites kapitel
könnten wir tatsächlich noch ein
bisschen stärker
die wirtschaftlichen aspekte im blick
nehmen insbesondere die milliarden
dieser möglichen unter anderem in
kurzarbeitergeld und was das eventuell
auch ein bisschen verschleiert aber
vielen dank für ihre einschätzung ihrer
information das machen wir wollen
nächsten mal herzlichen dank vielen dank
größe nach berlin danke rainer hoffmann
vorsitzender der strecke bleiben sie
gesund